Okay.
The first video of the series
presented logic as a language,
a formal language that can help us think
about human language and individual
languages.
Now that we've seen why it's useful to
have a logic that's a formal system with
constant symbols at variable symbols.
I want to explore the parts of statements
and the constants and variables you
use to represent those parts.
Small parts of statements in logic,
so we'll start by dividing all statements
we could make into subjects and
predicates.
So far I presented words and statements
as symbols and used even simpler
alphabetic symbols to stand for
those words and statements like x,
n p.
Now in our symbols,
names something or focused on a
topic they're called subjects.
All of the individual constants we've
used so far like h for house and he for
the English language
can be used as subjects,
but subjects are part of a larger frame.
The frame includes the predicate,
which relates information
about the subject or subjects.
If you went through my intro
to the verb in its arguments,
especially the first two videos on
arguments and valence. See you've have,
you've got a linguistic perspective
on subjects and predicates.
You saw that verbs, take
arguments, send the Bourbon.
It's arguments from the
core of a sentence frame,
but you don't need to be a linguist to
get a feel for the difference between
subjects and predicates and you don't
need to take it all the way back to
Aristotle's heavy discussion on the topic.
You just need to consider
the two terms in relation.
The rough idea is that a subject
is a term that a predicates said.
Something about at a predicate is a term
that says something about a subject.
Let's look at those predicates. If a
predicate says something about a subject,
it makes sense that a predicate
does not include the subject.
Some examples of predicates are
is red is a language or sees.
Let's simplify these predicates
by using constant symbols.
Unlike a variables x,
Y and Z and individual
constants like h and e,
the symbols for predicates or capital
letters using capital letters for
predicate Constance is a convention and
logic so the predicates send up looking
like this.
Our first two predicates.
Say something about a single subject.
For example,
we could say that English is a language.
Then we could write English
is a language in logic.
That third predicate
has multiple arguments.
We could say John Sees Mary or Jill sees
the movie and we'll write the sentence
in symbolic logic like this.
Notice that the predicate comes first.
This is true when the predicate constant
is the predicate of a single individual
or when it's the predicate
of multiple individuals.
Notice that we used constants for a
predicates and that holds true for all
predicates and basic logic,
but let's scrap our individual constants
for a moment and speak a bit more
generally about using
variables with our predicates.
Instead of speaking specifically
about English as a language,
we might want to find out whether or not
something is a language. In this case,
we'll use x to stand for that.
Something I mentioned in the last lesson,
but it's worth repeating
for clarity's sake,
that that variable x can be filled by
many values but it doesn't stand for any
specific value.
A fancy way of saying this is a variable
ranges over the domain of discourse
where the domain or the universe of
discourse is just a set of everything that
the variable can represent.
So when it comes to is a
language you can think of.
This combination of predicate and variable
as blank is a language and this one
as blank is running at this one.
As you guessed it,
blank sees Blake more precisely.
Blank sees some other Blake.
Of course,
if you have strong analytic skills,
you can always think in terms
of the variables. Instead,
x is a language x is running at x
sees why with variables in mind.
Let's look at the valence.
See of our predicates.
This refers to the number
of terms that are predicate.
Says something about the predicate
is a language at is running.
Say something about one term which
we can symbolize with the variable x.
So they have a valence of one.
The predicates sees on the other
hand leaves two slots open for us,
one for x and another for a y.
So it has a valence of too,
but let's not stop there.
The deceptively short predicate gave has
a place for a giver x a thing given why
and they give ie or recipient z.
So the valence is three.
We can even turn to these
variables themselves, x, Y and Z,
and view them as terms with zero valence.
If you're familiar with
mathematics or computer science,
you'll see similarities between these
concepts and the concepts of function and
argument or sub routines and parameters.
The specialized applications of those
terms have been refined from logic.
Now let's back up for a moment.
Consider something I mentioned
in the first logic video.
Whole logical statements maybe
represented just by the symbols p and Q.
This gives you options.
You won't always need to drill down
to the level of individual predicates.
And this may even be a better option if
you're evaluating statements as a whole.
Okay. Now you've gotten a bit of a handle
on subjects and predicates and logic.
So here's some ordinary language
statements to translate it into London.
Yes.
So you've seen the simplest and
stand for words and statements.
You understand constants and variables,
and now you know something
about subjects and predicates,
but this is all amateur stuff.
It's time to move on and look at
quantifiers and bound variables,
which will really tighten
up your logical statement.